[Musique]
raphaël paillard est ici dans son
premier concert de directeur artistique
de l'orchestré symphonique de montréal
ne connaissez rien de musique encore
moins classique jusqu'à l'âge de 14 ans
sa famille non plus à puerto la cruz au
venezuela
sauf son grand frère qui lui fait
découvrir ce qu'on appelle avec
vénération el sistema que la musique et
sans droits notre problème c'est très
important pour tout le monde pour tous
et spécialement pour tout le monde
n'importe hacker la classe sociale pour
tout le monde il avait un don pour la
musique et ne le savait pas si elle est
donc le père du sistema le visionnaire
si cet homme rose et antonio abreu
économistes et musiciens qui en 1975
décide d'utiliser la musique pour sortir
les enfants pauvres surtout des rues des
villes du venezuela ravagé par la
violence
pendant ce mois je me considère comme un
travailleur social pour moi la musique
c'est du travail social au plus haut
degré ce sont des défis pour notre
systéme à la musique est une arme noble
contre la pauvreté contre la drogue
contre la violence central de la rose et
antonio abreu décédé en 2018 notre
collègue marie ève bédard l'a rencontré
à caracas en 2012
el systema le système est reconnu dans
le monde entier et il est copié il forme
des musiciens mais c'est important
uniquement au sein d'un orchestre
elle affecterait l'apport avec l'aspect
le plus terrible de la pauvreté c'est la
solitude et le mépris public alors
qu'istres fait naître un sens d'identité
et d'estimé de soi chez les enfants
c'est très important et en plus cela
rend leurs parents fiers et heureux
selon lui les enfants les plus pauvres
ont encore plus le droit d'avoir de bons
instruments de bons professeurs les
constater pendant toutes ces années où
j'ai observé la trajectoire des enfants
qui s'intègre dans le système à la
transformation de leur vie et total
radical
c'est une transformation profonde de la
façon de penser de la façon d'agir
la façon de concevoir son rôle social
associé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans ce système financé directement par
tous les gouvernements parfois tant bien
que mal on parle de centaines de
milliers d'enfants transformé par el
sistema et de centaines de musiciens de
très grand talent et des vedettes
en septembre 2012 l'orchestré simon
bolivar du venezuela donne un concert
avec le philharmonique de los angeles
chef d'orchestre gustavo dudamel les
lèvres le plus fameux du système à
raphaël pas y aller en fait partie il
joue du cor français son instrument de
prédilection il s'est reconnu dans les
images de notre reportage de l'époque
mais il a déjà commencé sa formation de
chef d'orchestre
le maestro abreu assistent à l'événement
c'est une consécration
c'est un maître exigeant tout est
question de discipline de travail des
disciplines 3 6 1 et à l'employer pour
être moins bien entamée et tout va très
vite dans le systema grâce à l'émulation
au sein de l' orchestre ce qu'ils ont
appris en scène très vite au nouveau et
surtout il ya cette recherche de la
perfection
la musique était un état et à être démis
la bloquer en deux tours texpos n'est à
la qualité nous cas d arrêt au calme
entre 1,38 et exploite aux arts etc et
sait ni comment s est venue elle
suprêmement dell'arte montre ma rapide
tous un progrès réel
ils n'ont qu'à pas rare d bout car il
n'est pas le seul
paris a fait la découverte d'une jeune
chef d'orchestre vénézuélienne issus du
sistema classe masque à nos 24 ans
la maestra qui va dynamiter la musique
classique dit france musique
elle dirige et surtout elle vit l'oeuvre
musicale et inspire les musiciens
[Musique]
el sistema touchés comme tout le
venezuela par les crises politiques
économiques et sanitaires
mais il va survivre raphaël en est sûr
mais les sédunois cet avocat ni sonia
est tellement des témoins
[Musique]
qui sait el sistema est peut-être ce
qu'il y a de plus stable en ce moment au
venezuela
jean michel leprince sera du canada
montréal